notre invité ce matin c'est philippe
martinez le secrétaire général de la cgt
bonjour philippe martinez
bonjour alors vous êtes avec nous
pendant 20 minutes pour un entretien en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale qui est représenté ce matin
par pascal jalabert rédacteur en chef au
groupe ebra des journaux de l'est de la
france bonjour pascal on va commencer
cet entretien par parler de la crise
sanitaire avec ceux des confinement et
ce calendrier précisé par le premier
ministre jean castex
hier soir la réouverture de certains
lieux et de certains commerces à la
mi-mai la levée du couvre-feu depuis la
réouverture des écoles dès la semaine
prochaine
c'est le bon calendrier selon vous
philippe martinez ça va permettre de
donner de l'air aux travailleurs aux
français on attend tous de pouvoir
sortir librement de sa table et les
tables de restaurants et cafés les
mesures annoncées hier
on les connaissait j'allais dire depuis
l'allocution du président de la
république n'a été confirmé mais
derrière ces annonces il ya toujours
ainsi c'est ça qu'il faut prendre en
compte quoi c'est ça se passera comme ça
si si le taux d'incidence baisse si les
places en réanimation se baissent parce
que je crois que là là là là le problème
le plus important c'est la question des
vaccins et de la vaccination est donc
c'est autour de ça il n'y a pas assez de
vaccins et donc ça reste le problème
majeur est alors justement dans la
décision pourrait ouvrir au mois de mai
et ce qu'il faut prendre aussi en compte
la vie économique l'économie doit
reprendre la vie économique elle est
prise en compte depuis le début
suffisamment de des changes parfois
musclées avec le miz de l'économie pour
vous dire que c'est quand même d'abord
ça qui a primé sur sur le reste et c'est
fort dommage ce qu'on appelle encore les
salariés de travailleurs de première
ligne bien ils savent ce que c'est que
d'avoir fait tourner l'économie et puis
d'autres aujourd'hui puisque il ya quand
même beaucoup d'activité aujourd'hui le
moins qu'on puisse dire alors justement
il est l'une des priorités
pour la vaccination accordés aux
travailleurs le 1er ce qu'on appelle
première et deuxième ligne ou pour les
plus de 55 ans faut-il élargir ses
priorités et faut-il peut être vaccinés
en fonction des les professions et des
salariés qui sont en contact faute de
revoir stratégie nation qu'il faut
élargir et puis compris la notion de 55
ans quelle est la différence entre un
professeur de 55 ans et de 54 ans
avaient ils vont être confrontés au même
public puis il faut aussi par exemple
pour l'enseignement parce que les écoles
ou vont ouvrir dans des conditions il ya
déjà dire il ya la théorie que constitue
la lettre du ministre à l'ensemble des
enseignants qui la pratique qui va être
beaucoup plus compliqué à gérer mais je
pense que là aussi même en dessous de 55
ans il ya dans des départements où le
taux d'incidence est très haut
seine-saint-denis qu'on cite souvent ou
me semble-t-il la moyenne d'âge des
enseignants est beaucoup plus jeunes
c'est des premiers boulots en général là
aussi il faut prendre il faut prendre
des mesures donc c'est difficile de
définir qui est prioritaire au pas et
c'est un public très large qui est
prioritaire
en effet à ceux qui ont du contact avec
le public mais aussi d'autres ont parlé
de la seine saint denis
du coup est ce que ça veut dire que vous
êtes plutôt favorable à une stratégie de
vaccination par territoire avec des
priorités par territoire il faut que le
le problème ça reste là les vaccins bah
oui il y en a pas assez
et plus les polémiques en tous cas les
débats autour d'un vaccin ou de deux
n'arrange pas le fait qu' on va quand
même voir le paradoxe qu'il faut
accélérer la vaccination et puis je
discutais avec mon pharmacien qui me dit
il ya des doses il ya des doses elle
reste là et puis on va plus en commander
parce que personne n'en veut donc je
pense qu'il ya vraiment si c'est tout
tourne autour de la vague de la
vaccination et des doses de vaccin le
gouvernement a une responsabilité sur
cette défiance vis à vis du accent
notamment du vaccin astrazeneca
au delà de la défiance et des discours
parfois contradictoires c'est pourquoi
il n'y a pas de vaccins qui sont
produits qui sont cons et et qui sont
produits en france et qui ont été pensés
en france on a un des groupes mondiaux
les plus grands en france en matière
d'industrie pharmaceutique sanofi et qui
nous avait promis rappelez vous fin
l'année dernière tous vous inquiétez pas
on s'occupe de tout il n'y a toujours
pas de vaccin et c'est un groupe qui va
supprimer qui suppriment des emplois
encore et notamment des emplois dans la
recherche
là il ya une responsabilité du
gouvernement qui doit taper un peu plus
du point sur la table une question sur
le télétravail classe kalou et donc le
télétravail alors certains salariés
trouvent que ça dure
de façon un peu longue les règles sont
très rigides
il ya certainement une perte un peu sens
collectif dans l'entreprise faut-il
assouplir ou alors laisser plus de choix
au dialogue dans l'entreprise je pense
que ça pèse sur voit aussi les
visioconférences
de rédaction le travail c'est du
collectif et donc forcément quand on est
en télétravail
on a des échanges mais par écran
interposé donc il ya besoin de règles
c'est de règles de protection mais
l'idée de revenir un jour par semaine ou
voir ses collègues de travail je pense
que c'est une épine mais on en revient
toujours au même problème quand les
risques seront moindres et bien il
faudra retrouver
par contre il faudra faire attention
parce que on trouve maintenant que le
télétravail c'est la bonne formule
il ya même des entreprises qui gagnent
beaucoup d'argent en réduisant leurs
locaux parfois même en les supprimant le
travail c'est du collectif
il faut croiser ses collègues il faut
discuter et ça ça doit être la règle
pour l'avenir du travail dont on parle
beaucoup
voilà ce que vous dites dans le monde
d'après il ya un moment fort à sortir du
télétravail du tout le monde enfin moi
je croise beaucoup de gens qui me disent
bon c'est bon mais enfin cette notion de
collectif de travail allait essentiel
est l'essentiel oui on a on a tous des 4
des qualifications des compétences mais
il faut les croisés faut les échanges et
puis le boulot on peut aussi parler
d'autre chose on peut parler
syndicalisme par exemple revendiqué
culture etc etc
à quoi on va parler à d'économie et de
la crise économique philippe martinez
car l'état a beaucoup dépensé pour
essayer de sauver l'économie c'est le
fameux quoi qu'il en coûte
emmanuel macron mais pour les prochains
mois le gouvernement envisage de baisser
les aides aux entreprises également
l'indemnisation du chômage partiel
il ya une concertation actuellement avec
les syndicats qu'est ce qu'il en ressort
pour l'instant qu'est ce qui va se
passer
il ya un prolongement à très court terme
d'un certains ont des dauphins
mais faut revenir sur le quoi qu'il en
coûte sur les milliards et les milliards
la question c'est à quoi ils servent
or les aides elles sont pas
transparentes
c'était déjà le cas avant cic etc et
donc nous ce qu'on demande c'est cnl
servent à quoi à maintenir l'emploi à le
développer ou à accélérer des
restructurations au moi ce que je
constate et je le vérifie à saint-claude
par exemple dans le jura la samedi
dernier c'est que les licenciements
continuent dans l'automobile des
constructeurs qui ont été largement aidé
continue à restructurer en interne et
leur réseau de sous-traitance et ça
donne et on continue donc les
délocalisations ce qui est le cas dans
l'automobile donc au delà de quoi qu'il
en coûte c'est à quoi sert cet argent et
il faut drame
il faut maintenir des aides moi je pense
aux hôtels cafés restaurants au secteur
du tourisme dont la réouverture va être
beaucoup plus progressive et là il faut
aider évidemment là que pour le les
salariés pour qu'ils puissent continuer
à vivre tout simplement
alors ça c'est sur le secteur
touristique qui est protégé mais sur les
secteurs non protégés qui vont un peu
être lancée dans les prochains mois le
gouvernement envisage de baisser
l'indemnisation du chômage partiel pour
les salariés de 84 à 72 % du salaire net
vous êtes favorable dont nous on est
favorable à le payer à 100% parce que là
aussi il faut faut être précis
les entreprises sont indemnisés à 100%
et les salariés à 84%
donc là aussi il n'ya pas l'équilibré et
quand on est mal payé
quand on touche 100 % de son salaire
vous imaginez les conséquences quand on
ne touche que 84% puisqu'il ya que les
smicards que les salariés qui touchent
le smic qui sont 100 % qui sont
remboursés à 100% mais qui touchent en
tout ou cela on est le pays
or l'argent n'est pas chez reims au
moins la france emprunte même parfois
taux négatifs
faut-il continuer à creuser la dette et
à se dire on a le temps on leur en
perpétuelle alors là c'est pareil la
dette c'est faut savoir de quoi on parle
pas ce que vous entendez tout à l'heure
par les deux là
de l'assurance chômage etc il ya une
partie de ces questions là qui sont
financées par les cotisations sociales
donc on peut s'interroger est-ce qu'il
faut continuer à exonérer un certain
nombre d'entreprises de cotisations
sociales parce que ça peut faire un
petit gain de pouvoir d'achat pour les
salariés parce qu'ils sont aussi
exonérées mais si quand vous êtes au
chômage vous êtes plus indemnisés quand
vous allez vous êtes malade vous êtes
moins remboursés donc les cotisations
sociales c'est une partie qui finance la
crise sécurité sociale ni à la deuxième
partie la dette publique qu'est ce qu'on
appelle écoutez il faut l'analyser là
une partie de la dette d'aujourd'hui
c'est tout ce qu'on a donné aux banques
lors de la crise financière il ya
quelques années
depuis est-ce que la dette en tant que
tel c'est un problème vous savez que la
dette privée c'est-à-dire la bête des
entreprises est bien supérieur à la
dette publique
personne n'en parle ça n'effraie
personne une entreprise qui s'endettent
pour investir on ne dit rien on dit
c'est normal quand l'état s'endette et
il devrait investir plus dans le bien
commun la servait investir pour
moderniser un hôpital ou pour en
construire un et bien c'est ça fait
nécessaire c'est indispensable
ce que ce que fait alors je suis pas un
adepte de baden mais enfin c'est quand
même assez impressionnant que aux états
unis qui est le pays l'antithèse de la
france on pourrait dire eh bien le
prennent au nouveau président de la
république il il faut s'endetter parce
qu'on a besoin de recréer de la
solidarité que les citoyens de ce pays
qu'ils aient les mêmes droits donc on
investit dans les routes dans les
hôpitaux etc
j'allais dire c'est presque le monde à
l'envers maintenant donc job island
c'est devenu une inspiration pour la cgt
c'est pas
enfin en tout cas c'est c'est à
constater ça dort même pas interpeller
que la cgt vous aussi je pense que oui
on me le milliard d'euros injectés dans
l'économie
bien investi 1 2 $ par nuit de dollars
investis c'est de l'investissement pour
alors évidemment le pays est beaucoup
plus mal en point en matière
d'investissements publics le nôtre donc
il ya pas besoin de beaux mais voilà on
considère pas on considère pas que c'est
de la dette c'est de l'investissement
c'est de l'investissement vous voyez
l'état monte à 28% du capital d'air
france où beaucoup à la sncf qui
subissent une lourde perte 1 ce qui est
logique
est ce que vous dites finalement il faut
que l'état garde cette part
l'investissement dans ces grandes
sociétés qui sont des emblèmes faut-il
saisir cette occasion pour remettre de
l'état d'insécurité sais c'est pas les
emblèmes c'est oui et les grimpeurs ne
pense pas que ça c'est des si vous
prenez la sncf mais on peut parler là
d'edf qui est menacé aujourd'hui service
public ces deux sont des entreprises
d'intérêt public l'énergie on en a
besoin
la mobilité on en parle beaucoup avec la
transition le tracé écologique donc ce
sont des investissements au service de
tous
après il faut que tout le monde puisse y
avoir accès hélas l'état un rôle de
régulation de deux n'ont pas faire à la
place de ceux qui travaillent mais
donner un cap donné des orientations
c'est ça le rôle de l'état philippe
martinez on va évoquer la réforme de
l'assurance chômage que le gouvernement
souhaite appliquer au 1er juillet est
d'ailleurs il y à une journée de
mobilisation à l'appel de la cgt
aujourd'hui contre cette réforme je
rappelle les mesures clé un nouveau
calcul des indemnités
une des clés une dégressivité pour les
hauts salaires et un bonus malus pour
lutter contre les contrats courts est ce
que vous pensez avoir gain de cause au
final et obtenir le retrait de cette
réforme tout cas on fait tout pour parce
que c'est une réforme injuste
vous parlez de bonus malus c'est pas
pour maintenant ça c'est plus tard c'est
dans un peu plus d'un an et on verra ce
que ça donne ce qu'il ya pour l'instant
il n'y a rien de concret vous rendez
compte que n'était pas un million sept
cent mille personnes sont concernées par
lé la deuxième partie de la réforme il
la première partie je vous le rappelle
c'est appliqué en novembre de l'année
dernière
on va on taxe utile a conclu le pont
pénalise qu'il à ceux qui ont ce qu'ils
sont rêches ou ceux qui souffrent déjà
parce qu'ils sont chômeurs vous avez
noté aussi que tellement fait ça à
précipitations qu'on va en plus de taxes
et 1 million 700 mille personnes parmi
ces 1 million 700 mille fois il n'avait
pas vu que les femmes en congé maternité
que ce qui était en arrêt maladie allait
encore plus être taxé
c'est proprement scandaleux est ce que
vous connaissez quelqu'un un jeune qui
quand il est à l'école il dit moi mon
futur métier sera chômeur aucun donc on
ne choisit pas d'être au chômage qu'on
subit et dans la période y en a beaucoup
qu'il subissent donc c'est proprement
ajuste ses c'est dans la logique du
quinquennat savez monsieur macro est à
la une de ses premières mesures en
arrivant il a supprimé l'impôt sur la
fortune
c'est à dire qu'il a donné à il a fait
un cadeau aux riches on arrive à la fin
de son chat et un quinquennat la mesure
qu'il prend 7 pénaliser encore plus les
chômeurs ou les futurs chômeurs ça je
crois que ça résume le quinquennat le
bonus malus sur les contrats courts
faut-il garder
il faut un malus parce que des bonus sur
la je vous en ai cité quelques-uns des
aides aux entreprises
il ya pire attaque depuis un an et demi
qui en a et d'ailleurs on cice par
exemple on peut se demander à quoi
crédit impôt compétitifs vers l' emploi
fin du quinquennat précédent influences
qui les a placés mais on le critiquait
déjà soufflé la place et lens mais le
gouvernement qui a suivi n'a pas changé
donc y'a des aides aux entreprises
aucun n'a pas besoin de plus par contre
il faut pénaliser les entreprises qui
abusent de la bio du travail précaire et
il y en a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup une
question sur la réforme des retraites
est ce qu'elle est définitivement
enterré selon vous c'est pas moi qu'il
faut demander ça
est ce que vous en pensez c'est c'est où
ça vu les mobilisations qui a eu l'année
dernière
je pense que le gouvernement aurait tort
de d'un nouveau jeter de l'huile sur le
feu dire autre chose à faire que de
rallonger le temps de travail
il faudrait plutôt le diminuer pour
justement créer des emplois alors
justement elle vous parle de
mobilisation le 1er mai la cgt
va défiler va manifester ou alors que vu
les conditions sanitaires vous allez
faire autrement
on a bien l'intention de manifester pas
tous pas tout seul d'ailleurs vous avez
noté force ouvrière solidaire effet sur
les organisations de jeunesse
on manifeste on a toujours plus ou moins
manifesté durant cette période avec les
précautions nécessaires avec nos masques
on est à l'extérieur
donc oui oui il faut que le 1er mai soit
une forte
il ya une forte mobilisation parce que
des mobilisations hoornaert vous citez
aujourd'hui c'est important c'est aussi
autour des questions de la culture de la
réouverture des lieux de culture mais je
vous ai cité la mobilisation à
saint-claude samedi dernier autour d'une
fonderie de cases ville depuis un petit
moment
viviez exactement c'est là à côté c'est
la banlieue autour de la somme des
salariés qui disent on a un savoir faire
on a vous nous parler de plan de relance
vous nous parlez de d'environnement
avoue délocaliser nos productions avec
renault est une entreprise ou l'état a
est actionnaire pour l'envoyer dans
d'autres pays c'est à dire qu'il ya pas
un problème de d'activité s'est on
supprime de l'activité en france pour
l'envoyer en roumanie et les salariés
que je connais bien me disait qu'elle
est là quelle est la place pour
l'environnement notre lieu de livraison
aujourd'hui notre client il est à 800 km
on envoie fabriquer les pièces en
roumanie
économiquement c'est trois fois plus le
prix du transport et environs pour
l'écologie pour l'environnement vous
mesurez ce que ça fait donc on supprime
des emplois
on continue à délocaliser et tout ça au
détriment de la planète et au détriment
de l'économie
monsieur le pardon monsieur le maire a
promis une table ronde sur ces questions
là on nous souhaitons qu'elle se tienne
rapidement et qu'on puisse montrer qu'
on peut travailler il ya les compétences
et c'est pas plus cher de travailler en
france on parlait du premier mais je
voudrais qu'on aborde
le fait syndical en france avec
notamment un sondage harris interactive
qui a été commandé par la cgt pour voir
comment les syndicats était perçu par
les français
une question la marque et avez vous
confiance dans vos organisations
syndicales 51% de nom philippe martinez
comment on fait pour redonner confiance
dans les syndicats jeu j'ai pu le
sondage en tête puisqu'il date un peu
mais il ya une différence
évidemment entre l'ensemble des français
et ceux qui travaillent parce que les
syndicats en général pourra peut-être
qu'on s'améliore mais on les croise
d'abord au travail donc il ya celle
inverse
parmi ceux qui travaillent ce qu'il faut
c'est que c'est des syndicats s'implante
encore plus dans les entreprises
ou quand le le délégué du personnel ou
la déléguée du personnel vous vous le
croisez vous savez quand on voit
martinez à l'intérieur dit peut-être qui
parle bien mais est-ce qu'il connaît
vraiment mes problèmes
alors que quand on côtoie et s'enlise
calice dans l'entreprise c'est mieux or
de ce point de vue là il ya un problème
dans ce pays c'est la répression
syndicale
c'est le gouvernement le patronat 10
heures il faut plus de poids pour les
syndicats mais dès qu'on essaye de créer
un syndicat dans l'entreprise
ça devient compliqué pour ceux qui
syndicats c'est quand même un problème
dans une démocratie donc plutôt que de
2,2 de pleurer des larmes de crocodile
sur sur le syndicalisme encourageons le
à s'implanter cercle et en tout cas nous
on fait notre boulot
mais quand on nomme des délégués
syndicaux faut pas que ça ça ça soit la
chasse aux syndicalistes et je pèse mes
mots quand je dis ça alors il ya une
autre question dans ce sondage qui m'a
marqué ça concerne le caractère
constructif de la cgt la question est
posée considère considérez vous la
société comme constructive il ya un oui
à seulement 44 % est ce que ça vous pose
un problème cette image de la cgt lui
d'ailleurs d'un syndicat qui est un peu
toujours opposé aux réformes
oui oui parce que s'est entretenue par
nous et puis on a beaucoup de
propositions mais elles sont pas assez
connus
on a fait nous on a proposé par exemple
un plan de rupture est le contraire du
plan de relance du gouvernement
c'est peu connu vous même je suis
patient vous le connaissez en détails
voyez donc il ya besoin qu'on fasse
mieux connaître nos propositions puis on
a certainement historiquement une
culture du nom il faut qu on équilibre
entre le fait qu'on soit pas d'accord et
que telle mesure mais qu'en face on
propose autre chose et la proposition là
je ne vois pas pourquoi on n'en parle
pas plus justement on va en train
présidentiel dès la rentrée probablement
est-ce que la cgt formulera des
propositions
évidemment pas sur tout mais moins sur
tout ce qui concerne le travail les
salaires les retraites l'assurance
chômage à destination de tous les
candidats potentiels jeu
en tout cas on leur fera réviser parce
que nos propositions
ils les connaissent on les croise même
quand ils n'étaient pas encore déclarée
on les a croisés on leur a dit voilà par
exemple la rixe les 32 heures
c'est une vraie proposition pour que
ceux qui ont du boulot travail - pour
l'essai du travail à ceux qui n'en n'ont
pas bon ben on verra s'il est candidat à
la route yen mais sur la fiscalité on a
des propositions sur l'école sur le
travail on a beaucoup beaucoup de
propositions
marine le pen est donnée gagnante par
les sondages et puis beaucoup d'ouvriers
d'employés votent pour elle
est ce que pour vous si elle est élue ça
changerait pour pour leurs droits
et puis tu arrives vous pas envie de
dire à ces gens là qui se trompe mais ça
fait longtemps qu'on leur dit on n'a pas
attendu 2021 pour leur dire oui c'est un
danger passé un danger pour la
république c'est un danger pour les
libertés
c'est du populisme parce que je ne vois
pas comment on peut dire retraite à 60
ans en faire quelque chose sur les
cotisations sociales dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure parce qu'elle
veut et exonérer les les grandes
entreprises de cotisation et mettre la
retraite a séduit c'est du mensonge
ceci dit la question que l'on doit se
poser et nous à notre place de syndicats
on interpelle le monde politique parce
qu'on n'a pas vraiment tenu bien sûr
c'est de dire pourquoi à chaque fois
vous vous réveillez
entre les deux tours en disant attention
elle est là qu est ce qui conduit
aujourd'hui ce que vous disiez les
ouvriers à dire ben on vote pour l enjeu
moi ce que j'entends c'est ben oui mais
on nous promet plein de choses avant
d'être élu et puis ceux qui sont élus
ils font tout le contraire
voilà à parler de réforme des retraites
on n'a pas sur les salaires sur
l'assurance chômage on nous promet des
emplois enfin il ya une souffrance dans
le monde du travail est une souffrance
parmi les chômeurs et et et la
responsabilité
elle est d'abord d'abord sur une classe
politique qui a fortement déçu les
citoyens peut-être n'y a pas eu assez de
mobilisation parce que et élire
quelqu'un lui dit rose occupe toi de
nous je pense que ça marche pas c'est tu
as promis des choses et bah on va
descendre dans la rue on va te montrer
qu'on nous on n'a pas oublié faut que tu
les fasse donc la première
responsabilité
elle est dans la classe dans une classe
politique qui on a l'impression
aujourd'hui que le rêve de tout le monde
c'est d'être au deuxième tour avec
marine le pen pour être sûrs de gagner
ça c'est un problème pour la démocratie
rapidement pour finir est ce que vous
croyez à une union de la gauche
ses fins moi j'espère une unité
syndicale pour qu'ils aient des
mobilisations voilà c'est ça mon souci
donc la gauche ça vous préoccupe pas je
viens de vous dire qu'il y avait besoin
que la classe politique l écoute et
elles prennent des mesures en faveur du
monde s'attaquent à la rentrée vous
allez essayer de mobiliser conjointement
avec laurent berger avec
premièrement vous à noter qu'on n'a pas
attendu la rentrée bref c'est là le
premier et tout le monde n'y est pas il
y en a pas mal
il ya un beau mâle et on va continuer
parce que je pense que sur la wii la
question des salaires la question des
salaires de des premières minutes je
vais écouter laurent berger il dit ça
apporte bon bain chaud qu'on soit
présent pour aider le monde du travail
ça ça pèsera sur les sur les futurs
candidats et et nous espérons sur les
programmes c'est la fin de cet entretien
merci philippe martinez d'avoir été
notre invité merci beaucoup
pascal pascal on va regarder oui elle a
une dans des journaux du groupe ebra les
dernières nouvelles d'alsace
une consacrée à thomas pesquet qui
reprend aujourd'hui son aventure
spatiale merci messieurs
[Musique]